Hello Freak bitches.
That's amazing.
You know what's really incredible is that,
uh,
people are using Siliciden,
um,
these days in what they call micro dosing,
taking very small doses and seeing these profound benefits.
Yeah.
Uh,
one of the things that I'm aware of is kickboxers are using it and kickboxers
are using it in a good buddy of mine is using it.
He says that he can see things happen before they happen.
Like it was almost like he's reading people's minds before they're about to do
something even on micro dose.
Yeah.
That's very interesting in an intense environment of sparring and,
and the,
the intense physical kinetic interaction of kickboxing said he's seeing what
people are going to do before they do it in a way that he's never able to do
quote unquote on the net.
Right.
No,
I'm not surprised at all.
I mean,
and why,
why aren't you surprised?
Like what do you think is happening?
Because I think that uh,
these things let you step out of your box a little bit.
They let you step out of your usual reference frame and notice things going on
in the environment.
That again,
this gating mechanism we were talking about where program to filter stuff out,
psychedelics temporarily disrupt that.
They let the background come forward and you notice things about the environment
that we're,
that normally you would suppress because they're not relevant to immediate
survival.
I don't know if you've read some of the work by Simon Powell.
He wrote the psilocybin the solution.
He writes very intelligently about psilocybin.
In this latest book,
the Mush Magic Mushroom explorer,
he talks about how silicide Siliciden is a lens.
So essentially you can think of it as a lens through which you can look at the
world.
You can look at natural phenomena and you will notice things about that,
those phenomena that you normally would overlook because we're programmed to do
it.
So in a sense he talks about how silicide but is a scientific instrument.
You know,
it's a lens through which you can look at the world and see aspects of it that
are always there,
but you've never noticed them before because we're programmed not to.
For example,
um,
you know,
carry Mola says is famous because his discoveries in molecular biology,
he attributes to his insights about molecular processes that he got from LSD
that he could get down with the molecules as he put it and see how all this is
working.
And obviously he invented a polymerase chain reaction,
which she got the Nobel prize for.
So it's not like this was a delusion,
it's a real thing that he was able to notice that no one else,
you know what I'm saying?
He was able to put himself in a place where he could notice these phenomenon.
And I think,
I think that's really true.
If you,
if you go to take a walk in the forest with an indigenous person,
you know,
who in some ways as in this less of this sensory gating in a more open place all
the time,
they will notice things about the environment,
you know,
that you are completely oblivious to until they pointed out,
and then now say,
Oh yes,
I never noticed the leaf cutter ants are behaving this way,
or these different things.
Their sensory,
uh,
sort of,
experience of a environment like the forest is very different than ours,
you know,
because we're used to,
we're just not out in nature the same way.
And I daresay I think one of the things that in some ways inserts a,
uh,
a barrier between us is literacy.
You know,
we're all literate,
right?
And we'd like being literate.
It's good that we're literate,
but in order to be literate,
you have to have this separation between the self and the external environments.
You know,
you have to pick up a book and read it.
I am here,
I'm the point of view.
Here's the book,
you know?
So that creates that relationship and you sacrifice,
you focus on one particular sensory modality and you sacrifice all the other
input that is coming up.
I don't know if I'm making Sam absolutely,
absolutely.
But,
but that's,
that's what these substances can do.
They can essentially reverse this background foreground relationship that we're
so used to suddenly what's right in front of you is not so important and you can
pay attention to the things in the background that you're normally your program
to suppress and ignore.
Because know you have to be ready for the saber tooth tiger to come across,
you know,
over the,
the mountain or whatever.
You know what I'm saying?
But,
uh,
it's good in that sense.
They teach different ways of perception,
you know,
and I think that's a very useful thing to learn.
You know,
the indigenous people call these psychedelics plant teachers and they call them
teachers for a reason.
You know,
much of the,
what you experienced comes directly from the experience,
but much of it also comes from your change perception and suddenly realize
there's a different way to be in the world.
There's a at different way to perceive what you experienced that normally you
don't.
Uh,
you know,
we're programmed to filter out.
I don't know if you've ever read or had a Stephen Buhner on your show.
No,
he writes very intelligently about this stuff.
He's written a book called a plant intelligence on the imaginal realm and it's
all about this,
you know,
uh,
this,
essentially what his rap is.
You can learn this,
you know,
you can learn this way of perceiving whether you do it with psychedelics or not.
You can actually learn it and it's a,
it's an interesting,
it's a better way to relate to nature or more of an alternative way to relate to
nature in any way.
I feel like we have these pre assume definitions of things that we rely upon
instead of seeing things for what they really are and you kind of,
yeah,
you box them up and you package them and you go,
oh,
well there's a car,
there's h and then one day you look at the car and you go,
that's a box that has a controlled explosion and Cayston iron and it rolls on
rubber tires.
That's exactly what I'm talking about,
right?
There's a different way to look at things if you step out of the box.
And yes,
it is all those things and it's also a car and it's that if you did that all the
time,
you'd never get anything done.
That's right.
Okay.